it is fairly well known that being a
long distance away from your significant
other is an undesired romantic situation
however it's not all bad
here are the upsides of long-distance
relationships I know it's hard but try
to take a moment to appreciate the
benefits of this situation for example
if you're not going out on fancy dates
you are saving money and everyone loves
money the dates you do go on are free
and provide valuable FaceTime with your
sweetheart
the best part you can video chat from
bed and since you don't share a bed you
can also fart in bed and when you have
nobody to impress on a daily basis you
can eat whatever you want without
judgement door eat Oreos of course
you'll likely miss all that kissing and
cuddling but without it you can channel
that sexual frustration into lots of
productivity
you'll be Employee of the Month every
month suddenly snail mail contains the
most wonderful surprise you could ever
receive bills be damned
you just got personal mail from your
personal mail and since you can't spend
time with your sugar boobs take this
part of your life to hang out with those
friends your sugar boo doesn't like like
bad influence Dan and constantly stone
Charlie you can also do those things
your sugar boo doesn't like to do like
go dancing you go girls it's also worth
noting that the picture texts you get
from your sweetheart will replace any
need for online stimulation now that is
being proactive and of course the times
you do see your significant other are
all the more worth it even though you've
been far away you've continued to grow
closer proving that a long-distance
relationship can be a relationship that
goes a long distance now I'm gonna go
fart in bed and eat some doreet Oreos
seriously guys d'Or eat Oreos
[Music]